all that being said you you you are
returning to you know a 17 and 19 team
that pretty clearly needs you um how
close do you feel uh and you know how
urgent does this situation feel from
just a professional it's it's urgent
from a professional standpoint because I
wasn't hurt you know at least my body
wasn't hurt uh my mind was hurt my
feelings was hurt uh
but it wasn't like some injury costed me
off the four so it's very urgent because
I've cost my team enough you know I've
cost this organization enough you know
and so um it's not a time for me to just
come back and be like all right I'm
going to take my time and get back when
I can no like you cost this yourself and
so you don't get the grace and although
I'm very appreciative of our
organization um you know number one for
the support um but number two like
they're putting the plan together ramp
up if it was up to me I would love to
come back and play right now reality is
it's probably not the best thing for me
or the best thing from an organizational
standpoint and and what that looks like
moving forward and and the risk of
injury and all those things but you know
there's a human component of this as
well and you
know um you sit home and you watch these
games and as a competitor you want to
help and so and then
returning
um it's funny
coach said welcome back in film
yesterday and BP start clapping and they
start and everybody start clapping I'm
like well I'm not sure I deserve a round
of applause
like but I'll take it but you know it
it's like in in that
like half joking but like you don't you
don't
just get
Grace and I I'll take my time and get
back when I can like I'm coming back
from a suspension not an injury and so
there's a huge sense of urgency and I
pushed it like crazy today and I'm G
push it like crazy every day um until I
can get back on the floor because number
one I think it's also important for
these guys to know and understand that
you know I'm I'm not approaching this
like I'm going just take my time and get
back when I can I'm going to do all that
I can to meet the requirements that I
have to meet uh with our Performance
Group in order to get back on the court
and I'm trying to do that as fast as I
can whatever work that requires that's
what I'm
do